Not just the price of food,
there is also the price of fuel
which is now close to €2 per liter.
Uh.
Those who bled
to buy 1 small house or 1 apartment
have seen the property tax explode.
Every visit to the supermarket,
every visit to the gas station or every invoice
are sources of anguish.
When you belong to the world of work,
when you only have your salary to live on,
1 small allowance or 1 small pension.
And what is the government doing about inflation?
Well,
1 fathom of the wind.
The proposal
Elizabeth'sed
limit of reselling fuel at a loss
is 1 lesson of thing
because, uh.
Here, uh.
In 15 days, huh,
the distributors agreed on uh.
Reject it, huh.
So there you go,
this measure,
well the government,
he buried it.
Last step,
the government has announced
1 tax on capital companies' profits.
It didn't take half an hour for 26
efg and other subscription dealers
explain that they would pass on
this tax on motorists.
Inflation is not a mysterious phenomenon.
Every event,
pandemic,
1,
global warming,
pushes,
uh.
Creates economic instability,
creates opportunities.
And those situations are uh.
The occasion
for capitalist groups to increase their margin.
And of course,
they are the most powerful of them,
uh.
Who take the most advantage of it to raise their prices.
Of course I mean energy companies,
of the tankers,
of. Refiners,
of the major maritime transport companies,
their speed is going wrong
their own system and the future
in fact their business.
Because of this inflation,
there was
therefore 1 increase in all interest rates
because this is the only way for the rulers to
to try to curb this surge in prices.
Except that this inflation now,
well,
it makes it almost impossible,
getting 1 credit to buy 1 car,
to buy, uh
Hum,
1 apartment,
1 house.
So we are confronted
now to the collapse of the market
real estate and perhaps
tomorrow to 1 full recession.
The height of cynicism,
French industrialists are pleased to have
gained in competitiveness
because wages in France have risen less
than in their competitors.
Well yes,
they make their profit
by stealing from the workers.
Well,
let's not let them.
In the United States,
automotive workers make
sorry for salary increases
because out there like here,
it is the only way to avoid falling into poverty
or decay.
And yes,
we have to fight
to obtain,
to extract the 400 to €500 per month
that we have lost.
Here,
in the last few years,
we must fight
to increase,
for salary increases
and to have these salaries indexed
on real price inflation.
This will not come from social dialogue,
it will come
as always of the struggles that we will have carried out.